how to promote your artwork so I got a
great question for one of my facebook
viewers Nigel love you guys who wrote in
to say hi Evan I'm a digital artist
could I have some tips on how I can
promote my artwork better so this is a
great question and I love artists
I love artists I love the creativity
that comes out and and it's such a
struggle for a lot of artists to
establish themselves and I'm involved
with a lot of artists in the dancing
community and it's hard it's hard to get
your brain sometimes wrapped around the
business side of actually getting out
there and promoting your work and
creating the movement and what you're
doing so I want to see you be successful
and here are my three tips to help you
get there number one is stand for
something you need to stand for
something you got to make me feel
something right as an artist now this
should be a little bit easier to
understand of all the strategies because
you're already connected to your work
you just got to pull me in and let me
know what you stand for you write to me
and tell me you're a digital artist
that's what most people will do but so
what there's a kajillion digital artist
out there right it's not hard to find
digital artists what makes you so
special and different why am I going to
talk about you on this video and
showcase your stuff tell me what you
stand for to make it easy for me to
remember you now check that your blog
and you have a lot of sci-fi fantasy
kind of stuff on there and it looks
pretty cool so maybe write to me and say
Evan I'm a digital artist who believes
that people should live out their
fantasies if that's something that you
feel powerful about then put it in there
I'm going to remember you now now you've
given me something that connects to me
because I kind of feel the same way too
so now we're connected at a deeper level
and I'm more willing to listen to what
you're all about and show it and share
it showcase it so figure out what it is
that you stand for complete this
sentence you know hi I'm Nigel I'm a
digital artist who believes that
building a blank
let me know what that is and any time
you're now introducing yourself to
people that's the line you're going to
use you're giving people a message to
understand and to share for you you want
people to talk about you you have to
make it easy for people to talk about
you that's something that they can share
okay so that's number one stand for
something
number two is model success anytime
you're trying to do something that you
have no idea how to do and this for you
might be promote your business you want
to look at who's already done it any
ghoul you have look at who has already
accomplished it what steps that they
take and how can you model that success
to make it work for yourself so for you
I would look at which artist you look up
to the most and how did they get started
how did they start to build a brand how
did they start to build a following not
how they do it now has already unknown
quantity how do they get started what
was the first big break and how can you
model that success the other thing I
look at is other entrepreneurs who you
look up to who have nothing to do with
art because you'll also learn from them
if it's Steve Jobs or Richard Branson or
Donald Trump or Oprah Winfrey or Martha
Stewart or whoever it is that you look
up to and say wow that's a really great
entrepreneur look at how they got
started to look at how they promote
their business - because you're going to
learn valuable lessons that you can
apply to your company even though they
have nothing to do with art so that's
number two model success
number three is collaborate find other
artists who believe in the same thing
you do who stand for the same thing you
do and that starts with you knowing what
you stand for
but then find other artists either
digital art or other genres who believe
in the same thing you do and find ways
to collaborate together so for example
I'd look at I'd look at musicians you
know why can't your art be featured or
be the main part of the musicians next
music video or next YouTube video your
art should be featured there and if you
and that musician on the same wavelength
both believe in the same thing both
trying to get people to feel the same
way but attacking it from different
angles you're doing it through your
digital art they're doing it through
their music
that's an awesome collaboration artists
are constantly looking for other ways to
collaborate and I deal
you're looking for people who are a
little bit ahead of you have a little
bit more traction than you so that you
can be exposed to their audience I do
this all the time with with people on my
youtube channel you know I I believe in
people I believe in entrepreneurs I wear
it on my shirts and the videos I make
are about believe somehow but what I
also like to do is collaborate with
other YouTube artists people who are
making videos who may not be on camera
but they're making videos sharing
stories or you know movie clips or
soundtracks and they mash them all
together I like giving those guys
exposure if they are on the same page if
they love the belief message and they
want to create a video about believe
I'll promote it I'll put it in my
channel I've done it for a few artists
and give them some more exposure
it helps me gives me content but it also
helps them get exposure to a wide
audience of people who are watching my
channel so when you know what you stand
for then you start making collaborations
with other people will even the same
thing because you're both trying to
attack the same goal from different
angles so that's number three
collaborate
so in summary how to promote your
artwork number one stand for something
number two model success number three
collaborate believe for those of you
watching you can subscribe to my channel
to check out more videos like this you
can support me by clicking on the link
in the description and leave a comment
let me know what you think I love seeing
those comments come in they really make
my day every day so thank you guys so
much and I'll see you soon
you